joining me today is a Canadian
businessman lawyer Member of Parliament
and the founder and head of the People's
Party of Canada
Maxine Bern a welcome to the Reuben
report thanks for the invitation
dave am very happy to be with you I am
glad you're here I am pretty sure how
many people are there in Canada roughly
37 median p37 so I've gotten about 36
million emails the show or on Twitter I
mean everybody in Canada seems to want
us to do this sit-down so so I'll do my
best so we shall see what there's many
reasons that I'm looking forward to this
chat and originally we're gonna do this
on skype and then you were gracious
enough to say let's say let's do this in
person the fact that somebody in Canada
is spreading the ideas of Liberty and of
the individual and limited government
all of those things is incredibly
inspiring to me and it's more of what we
need down here too but let's just start
first with a little bit of your
biography for people that don't know
anything about you yes I'm a lawyer I
did also a course in businesses before
and I work in the private sector in
Montreal Quebec in the financial sector
I was VP of Financial Institutions and
after that I work with the module
economic Institute that's a free-market
think tanks like maybe the Mises
Institute and like that I was VP over
there and in 2005 I had a meeting with
Stephen Apple at that time it was the
leader of the Opposition before the
election in 2006 and so it was looking
for some ideas to be able to have some
seats in Quebec as you know Quebec is
the francophone part of the country and
so we had a good chat together and I
told him you know there's two important
things that you must say to Quebecers if
you want to win first you must respect
the Constitution because in Quebec if
you remember we had a to referendum and
we we still have a separatist political
party at the parental level so I told
him you know respect the Canada
and constitution don't interfere in
province or jurisdiction and everything
will be okay and also lower taxes income
tax to Quebecers and all Canadians and
at the end that was I think a good
proposal for Quebec but also for all
across the country and he decided to put
that in his platform and he asked me to
run with him in 2006 so I decided to run
and my riding my district it is in both
near Quebec City it's after all
afterburn riding and I went there
because my dad was an MP under Bryan
Maroni for 13 years and so when I came
in both in 2006 to run the director of
my campaign told me Maxime we have a
problem with you because I was working
in Montreal I was not in the writing he
said you have a name my dad was very
well known but you don't have a first
name
so my goal at the end of the campaign
people must know you so I did a good
campaign and at the end I won and also
Stephen Harper we formed the government
in 2006 a minority government 2008 a
minority government and I was industry
minister at that time I did a big
deregulation in Telecom and that's why
people at that time they they call me
the Albertan from Quebec because in
Alberta there are very free markets and
Quebec at the pine-sol level we have a
big fat and socialist government so and
ideally great the telecom industry it
was a big success
and after that Primus authorized me to
be the Foreign Affair and I was a fun
affair for a year and I resigned and I
came back in the cabinet in 2010 and I
was Minister for small business and
after that Minister for State for
agriculture and so we had a majority
government in 2000 and
eleven and so we did some reform and
after that in 2015 and tweedle when in
power and I'm still a member of
parliament and upper resigning as the
leader of the party and the fun is
coming right now because I decided to
run for the leadership yeah and I create
after that I didn't win with forty-nine
percent of the votes and I was the most
people tallien candidate and I had a
very strong platform about individual
freedom personal responsibility actually
the four teams of our platform was
individual freedom personal
responsibility respect and fairness and
all our policies were based on these
principles that was very successful at
49 percent and you know I was the only
one to say we must abolish corporate
welfare one good percent we must also
cut foreign aid and and do a lot of
changes like that on the economy and
also on the immigration I had a strong
platform so I didn't win I tried to walk
with the new leader and Russia try to I
wanted the leadership of the
Conservative Party of Canada to add up
some of our reforms because that was
very popular and a year later he told me
that they don't want me anymore they
won't take any of all of the ideas that
I put forward and also I did a couple of
tweets that didn't like and so I
resigned from the party and in September
I decided to create the People's Party
of Canada yeah all right so your basic
political pedigree yeah
is there an inherent sort of oddity of a
libertarian trying to go into government
where most people that go into
government want to grow government they
believe that if only their policies were
instituted they could have a better
government that could do more and so on
versus a libertarian comes in you cut
regulation you wanted to cut some
programs etc etc it's almost like you're
trying to shrink the thing that's also
your job now you've had real jobs also
so I suspect you could look at it
perhaps a little bit differently yeah
because you know was in the private
sector before and I know that too much
government it is not bringing prosperity
and kind of Austrian economies also like
Mises and all you know my my prefer
website is mrs. org so I'm on the
economy I can call you can call me a
libertarian but I'm not a really Bert
Ryan because really Burton will ask for
open borders or no more regulations or
legislation on drugs and so I don't
believe in that I think we must have a
state that will have some regulation
basic regulations so how do you figure
out where that line is that's been one
of the ends that I talk about with a lot
of different guests and that sort of
seems to be a little bit of a difference
between people who consider themselves
classical liberals and libertarians
where there's a little more say hand of
the state on the classical liberal side
libertarians it's hard to know where
where the end is you know we are we just
in Mad Max so for me it's it's all about
the economy that's the most important
and yes you know our social policies
must be for more freedom and personal
responsibility and I tried to make a big
difference with the state and the
economy like we did in the past with the
states and religious you know so that's
always important to have this difference
and on the economy it's easy to be a
libertarian and Apple it's easier to be
a libertarian and a politician because
you know it's all special interest group
that are coming to you and they want a
privilege or or or more more subsidies
or things like that so I'm making the
line when I'm saying you know I want me
what I want I want to work for all
Canadians and not for a special interest
group and when I don't know a special
interest group is coming to us and they
just want to promote their privilege or
to keep their privilege that would be
easy for me to say no I won't do that
the best example was the the cartel that
we have in Canada in in Supply
Management that's a socialist system
that Pierre Elliot Trudeau put forward
45 years ago where milk poultry and eggs
the producers are fixing the price and
fixing the production for the Canadian
market they cannot export so Canadians
are paying twice the price for meal
poultry and eggs if you compare that
with the price that you're paying here
in the US so these cartel is very
powerful and when they came to me and
they wanted to keep their privilege I
say no you know will abolish that will
have a transition period you'll be able
to export I believe in a real free
market its if a free market is good for
every industry must be good also for
these people so what's the
counter-argument on that though if
Trudeau now yeah not the old Trudeau but
if our courage we get or your country
yeah was giving the counter-argument on
why you wouldn't free that up yeah that
just because he doesn't believe in free
market economics but it's because it is
a powerful lobby and also they want to
keep seats also and they're very
powerful in rural areas in the country
and and so for their powerful second is
buying in their arguments that you know
if we have mail from the US or eggs from
the US that won't be the same quality
and we need to stop that for being sure
that we can control the quality of our
products and so that's another argument
but for me you know when you have a
legislation everybody must respect that
so if you want to export to Canada your
eggs or your poultry or your milk you
must follow the Canadian legislation and
regulation that's that's a new deal and
but it's it's it's the powerful they are
very powerful so they the thinking is
they want to keep not only to do but
also also my former party the
Conservative Party of Canada the NDP
also they they are too afraid to to just
just listen to Canadians they think that
all we have a good system and eating
that carrion
the thing that Canadians don't
understand that system they think that
Canadian don't understand that they're
paying twice the price so the more I
speak about that the more popular it is
and that was very important in my
campaign for the leadership and it is
also part of our platform right now so
answering your questions why do you want
to keep that cartel I think it's only
for political reason so is the idea of
Liberty and personal responsibility and
some of the other things that you're
running on are these oddly new in Canada
and I say that because when when you
started coming on my radar about a year
ago I saw people started tweeting about
you there were a lot of people saying
something to the effect of wow if a
libertarian is needed in Canada then
something really must be wrong there as
if there was no need for it for a long
time but maybe something unique is
happening now
yeah people are ready for the new ideas
and I think people are fed up with
traditional politicians that are saying
something at the end they oppose it the
other day a politician that tried to
please the special interest group so
what I'm doing you know I'm doing
politics differently and you know
there's no political correctness for our
party I'm saying what I what must be
said for better policies in this country
in Canada sorry
and so the I think people are ready and
and what's happening actually right now
you know it's good to have the right
ideas but it's good it's better to have
the right ideas at the right time and I
think the timing is very good for us for
me because we have a government in
Ottawa right now the Trudeau government
that are spending a lot of money huge
deficit people they don't see and we
don't know when they will balance the
budget it must be around 20 2014 oh is
that the deficit of today all the taxes
of tomorrow so a huge deficit huge taxes
in Ottawa and the economy is so so right
now in Canada so people are looking for
a kind of alternative and and I think
the timing is good for me because
in a poll is 57% of Canadians said
Ameobi a month ago that they're ready to
vote for a new party so we are very new
party four months a month old and
they're ready to vote for a new party
and not voting for the traditional
parties something is happening I think
the big government in Ottawa
every time putting a lot of regulations
and a lot of subsidies to businesses you
know the government bailout the GM a
couple of years ago more than 2.5
billion dollars and GM said two months
ago that they will leave Canada yeah so
it's a waste of money we're giving a lot
of money to big businesses and all the
other politicians are saying it's okay
we must tell business what I'm saying
yes we must help businesses but every
businesses having a fair policy that is
to lower taxes to every businesses and
not giving subsidies and picking winner
and loser so I think people are ready
for a change they're seeing what's
happening in our country and they know
that we're not going in the right
direction right now so let's talk a
little bit about regulation yeah because
I think a lot of people think especially
if they're on the Left right now they
think if you say I'm cutting regulation
well first they go to environmental
regulation yeah I think that's what they
think first so I do want to ask you
about that but also they think if you're
just talking about it purely in a
business level but that means that
capitalism will then run amok cuz you
know that all of these businesses will
then start dumping in the rivers and
doing shady deals with each other and
competition will be crushed in all of
those things so you want to do business
or environment first on the regulation
front yeah I think let's do let's do
business person yeah let's do business
first you know business must answer the
needs of their consumers so a consumers
are asking for better products and for
products that will respect the
environment that's why they are asking
for electric cars and so you don't
always need regulation to force that the
free markets
the wish of the people will force
businesses to adopt their practice in
the right way and so when you have when
you have a real free market and when you
you have competition it's always good at
the end for the consumers you'll have a
better products and you'll have lower
prices but at the same thing the way at
the same time the way that they are
producing their products will change
right now you know people the best and
some people are telling me you know we
must have you know cooperate or social
cooperated we call that corporate social
corporate wealth no no corporate social
identity a corporation must be socially
well oh they have like a social
awareness and I said you know not really
because a corporation first must make
profits if they don't make any profit
they won't be able to do anything so if
they're profitable it's because you
wants their consumers wants their goods
and hundred products so that's the first
goal of our cooperation to make products
and and I think that you need regulation
but what we're doing right now every
time that something happened we put a
new regulation but they must be
responsible of their actions
corporations and individuals so that
that's important for me and I think
Canadian understand that yeah what about
on the environmental side I think yeah
this is the big one I think he's been
for people who can understand free
market I think you just can't leave this
environmental issues up to to private
companies yeah you know you can sue a
corporation if they don't respect the
regulations actually you know clean
water it's very important but you know
when you have facilities that are owned
by the government or by the
municipalities everything must be public
if they are doing person and things like
that
if the water is clean or not when it's
not public you cannot you cannot sue
them if they don't if they don't respect
the regulation so I remembered
Margaret Thatcher in Europe the way to
clean water over there was to have a
regulation saying every test that you're
doing and that was done by
municipalities public entity must be
public and you will be responsible to be
sure that you respect the regulation she
just put a regression on that every test
was public and five years later the
water was cleaner that it was before
because they didn't want to be sued they
didn't want to be so so they were
responsible so when you have a real free
market what everything is on the table
and you know the information that's
bring usually a better quality of water
or land and so you have property right
for that and property right it's the
basics of all that but speaking about
environment now the debate in Canada its
climate change yeah so so everybody want
to do something about climate change and
I'm the only party who said you know we
won't do anything environment in Canada
it's a shared jurisdiction with
provinces and the federal government and
I don't believe in the Paris Accord I
don't believe that kinda would be able
to achieve the goals that they put in
the Paris Accord and actually the UN and
the radical environmental in Canada said
the same thing that we don't want to
impose a carbon tax of $20 a ton and he
must impose a carbon tax of at least
$200 a ton if you want to achieve its
target so at $20 a times it will be only
a distortion for the economy and and
hardworking families will pay our prices
so that's why you know I don't believe
in Paris Accord and I think that we must
not impose new regulation on that we
must let provinces and other provincial
government if they want to have a
cap-and-trade like they have here in US
and other kind of a process for that for
us I want to have a program that will
maybe be very strong on clear water
clear hair something that people
understand and having the property
rights that will work and more
information you need more information at
the same time to be sure that people
will understand if
Lake is clear or not yeah so I'm glad
you mention that because it seems to me
that it's about information and being
able to get your messaging across so for
example the Paris Accords which
obviously the United States pulled out
of it seems very easy if you listen to
the media it was very easy we have to be
part of the Paris Accords and then if
you ask anyone what the Paris Accords
are they have no idea if you ask them
loans in a binding is there any you know
is there anyone watching to make sure
any of this happens they have no idea
and the answer is no I just read last
month that despite the despite the u.s.
pulling out of the Accords that right
now the u.s. is meeting most if not or
exceeding all of the standards that be
of course so how much of this is just
about getting your messaging across
because this will shift us a little bit
to talking about the media yeah which
you had an interesting relationship with
yeah you're right about that you know
it's all about virtue signaling for a
politician and but I think can you
didn't understand that they understand
when I'm saying you know the Trudeau
government actually right now they are
appropriate they are saying something to
the population knowing that it won't be
able to achieve that so I prefer to tell
the truth saying you know we won't think
that and we won't do anything to achieve
that and we won't spend 2.3 billion
dollars to send that to African
countries to help them to fight climate
change I think we must help Canadian
first so that's part of our platform but
the other party like the Conservative
Party also they don't want to have a
carbon tax but they want to impose more
regulations on Canadian businesses and
that's not the solution but they try to
please maybe the media but also a
portion of the population and I think
that you know when you explain and
that's what I like in politics you know
I like to explain our policies and why
we we are having the right policies
based on freedom and responsibility and
when you explain that the more you
explain I think the better people
understand it and the more more people
will want to vote for our party so for
me when I'm the only one to speak
against the Paris Accord
they're a huge clientele there and it
won't hurt me it will help me at the end
and um you know my my deal with
Canadians is be true tell what you
believe in and have some debates we'll
debate and that's important for me
so yes the media are playing an
important role but we need to use also
the social media and that's why you know
I'm very pleased to be here to speak to
the American audience and Canadians
audience and just try to have a
conversation with them and you yeah well
what's the state of the media you guys
have a whole different set of problems
there what is going on with the CBC you
just saw everything else in Canada yeah
you know we have the CBC I like how your
whole body language yeah we have the CBC
and the federal government is giving
about 1.3 billion dollars a year to the
state broadcaster the CBC and in French
it's kudzu Canada and I'm the only
politician and it's but it's a very
popular policy that we must cut that
because it is unfair the CBC are
competing with other private broadcaster
for the advertising and also they
receive money from the government so it
is not fair we must cut the CBC and I
what I want I want the CBC to get it a
bit like PBS in the state if they are so
good they will be able to have money
from their viewers but also the CBC they
are editorial board or a little bit I
will be very very kind a little bit left
is yeah so very young yeah yeah it's
worse in French though the radio Canada
in French or more leftist than CBC
sometimes it's is there a reason for
that you know it's like your media here
it's a bit but but the worse thing is it
is funded by the government yes so so if
you're I don't know CNN and you don't
receive any phone by the government and
want to to
be on the left it's your corporate
decision but the CBC must be more
neutral and they're not so that's the
big problem that we have in Canada the
way to fix that it's first of all CBC
must be must receive money from their
viewers first and second the government
must if the government is giving money
to a CBC we must know the what's
happening and maybe the executive of the
CBC must be before the Parliament once a
year to explain their editorial policy
but that being said the media we have
the CBC we have the traditional media
but when you're a real conservative or
right-wing politician you don't have the
same coverage then the Liberals or the
left they're having in in these
traditional media do you think in a
weird way that that's working to your
favor now because at least in the
circles that I can see you seem to be
the hottest Canadian politician despite
the fact and it's maybe it's fueled by
maybe they're not despite maybe because
of the fact that you're the outsider
from the media and people are so fed up
with the media that it's like oh here's
this guy doing it you know yeah it's
circumventing it and also you know when
the media the traditional media are
writing something about us or my party
that it's not true I will call that I
will and I'm very very factual on on
social media and Twitter about it and
you know I don't try to please everybody
or I don't write to please the media
they have to do a job if they're fair
it's okay if they are not fair we'll be
out there and and I will I will argue my
case and that's not all all the
pollution the pollution I'm not doing
that they want to be fine with the media
they don't want to have a fight with the
media and for me I will have a fight
with a journalist if is not doing its
job and I think people appreciate that
so yes when they are doing something not
objective on our policies on my party
that can help
again because you know the credibility
of journalist it is not the same with
people like you on social media people
have another way to find their news and
their little bit more critics towered
the traditional journalist and yes I
agree with you that can help me yeah
that's a politician are you able to
debate some of your political opponents
these days I mean to anyone in Canada
put these kind of talks on television
where you can actually get into the
ideas no usually when I'm on traditional
TV in Canada it's all about you know and
506 minutes yeah I want to get yeah I
mean yeah yeah they want Leon to have it
and they don't give you enough time to
answer the questions and go deeper in
the subject but that's why I use social
media that's why I'm prison in social
media so but you know I need to deal
with that and I think it's going very
well right now
so how does this all linked to just sort
of a state of free speech in Canada
because there does something seem to be
something particularly unique yeah in
Canada which is why I've had so many
Canadian guests and why Canada is
usually our second or third most mute
country obviously there was the Jordan
Peters who didn't was c16 yeah there's
what happened with Lindsay Shepard at
yeah Wilfred Laurier yeah yeah you've
got GAD sat up there who's always
fighting the Battle of free speech is
there something is it is this new what's
happening related to political
correctness in Canada yeah I think first
of all that started 40 years ago in the
university in Canada like in the US but
now what's happening there's some
politician who believe in that and with
that motion m1 which we the bill see 16
now these people that were that we're on
the school couple of years ago 40 years
ago now some of them are politicians and
you have this debate right now and it's
it's good for us that we have Jordan
Peterson and people like that we must
fight I think we must not take for
granted in Canada or freedom of
expression free speech and and we must
fight and I'm doing that as a politician
and you know with that bill c16 that was
crazy bill you know Jordan they want to
force his Jordan to speak with a
transgender not he or she but what was
the word was whatever they want whatever
they want yeah but there's no obligation
you know hey there's no big Asian to
please everybody yeah that what this all
comes down to though that people just
don't understand the fundamental
responsibilities of government in a free
society I mean if we were boiling all
this into one thing yeah that seems to
me to be it yeah you don't want the
government to tell you what to do you
don't want the government to tell you
what to say you know it's the basics of
our democracy and actually you know one
of our candidate Laura lein because
we're we have three by-elections in
Canada at the end of February the 25th
of February and I will have candidates
the People's Party of Canada will have
candidate and one of our candidate local
in in BC Burnaby BC in that riding she
at the Panchala ball fight for gender
against the gender fluidity in BC in the
school it's a provincial jurisdiction
they wanted to teach at school to young
kids that if you're a boy you may not be
a boy and if you're a girl you may not
be a girl and you can choose your sex
the state wants to impose that and to
teach that to young people and locally
ancient no I I don't want that I don't
want the state to tell us what to do in
that must be the responsibility of the
parents you don't have to put that in
the mind of a young boys six or seven or
five years old so but when she decided
to be our candidate all the mainstream
media's over Bernie and I said you know
she has the right to her own opinion and
that's a great debate that they had at
the potential level now she's doing
politics at the federal level but you
know they were tried they were trying to
look at her like you know
maybe a crazy candidate because she she
she has some some opinions and strong
opinions but you know because I believe
in freedom of speech our candidates can
have opinions like that we have
candidates that are pro-choice we have
candidates that are pro-life but just
ain't we're doing the Liberals they
don't want any pro-life candidates so
for me my party must be like the are
Canadian Society so yes I will tolerate
different point of view yeah but people
must be all V on our programs a program
that's very important
yeah but yes we have these debate right
now in Canada about the state and posing
some some values that I think that's not
the role of government yeah is it
actually part of the policy of the
Trudeau government that you if you're
pro-life that you actually can't be you
know in the party platform it's a party
platform yeah if you're a pro-life
person you cannot be a candidate for the
Liberal Party of Canada
I'm just saying Trudeau said that
[Music]